STEPHANIE WONG: So
I think maybe we
can start by giving the audience
some context about Quantum
Metric.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
it got started and
your push to the cloud?
MARIO CIABARRA:
Yeah, absolutely.
So we started in 2015.
And really, the idea--
I started my career in retail,
in the early '90s, I think.
It's been a while.
And there's this
magic that happens
when you walk into
a store and you
are seeking to purchase
some specific good, clothing
or jewelry.
I started my career out in
the retail clothing industry.
You'd be buying an airline
ticket, engaging with a bank,
and there's this
special touch that we've
perfected over
millennia that, when
I had that physical
engagement with the person,
I can understand when
they have a need, when
they are looking for help from
an associate, or et cetera.
And as we have progressed
on to digital, how do we
deliver these incredible
unique experiences,
these touches that we have
in our physical engagement?
How do we do that well online?
And so that was the challenge
that we set out to do.
And you know, there's
a picture here
of what it looked like in 2015.
And maybe some of you that are
in startups can relate to this.
This is, you know, two guys
in a room with a Kanban board,
just chugging away
at code and design.
So it was a really fun
start back in 2015.
We've gone a long
way since then.
And so we've had some
incredible success.
So, just to kind of catch up
and just in the last year,
we've had 400% growth
year over year.
We've been fortunate enough to
take $26 million of funding.
And we have 80-plus
experts around the world
to help our customers
engage in delivering
their best on digital.
STEPHANIE WONG: And that
was your series A funding?
That seems like a big number.
MARIO CIABARRA: It was.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can you
tell us about that a bit?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah.
You know, we've had so much
success at enterprises,
engaging with some
of the best brands--
United Airlines, Alaska,
eBay, Western Union, StubHub,
Ticketmaster, Bed, Bath.
We've had such an
incredible engagement
of how we empower those large
enterprises at delivering
their best on digital.
And when you get that kind
of success with the largest
of brands-- and even
being a small company--
there's some excitement.
And so with that, we
were fortunate enough
to have-- one of the best
venture firms out there
of private equity is
Insight Venture Partners.
So, really blessed to have so
much success at an early stage.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
And is that your team
in a cube formation?
How long did it
take you to do that?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so we
like to have a lot of fun
at Quantum.
And so this one is just one
of our team get-togethers.
And we all-- we
threw up a drone.
And it was quite fun.
So I think one of the great
things about startups--
and you know, really,
anyone's workplace--
it's got to have a lot of fun.
So we do that here at Quantum.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
So I see you had two
people on that 2015 photo.
And now you've grown.
And talk about your
push to the cloud
and where you started
compared to now.
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so I
think we all have our strengths
and weaknesses.
I know my weakness is
not-- it's not about,
I don't design infrastructure.
I don't design data centers.
And so I'm embarrassed
to show this picture.
But literally, this
is just last week our,
quote, "data center" on prem,
in our Colorado Springs office.
And the funny story
about it recently
is that there was
a bombogenesis.
There was a big storm
in Colorado Springs.
And we literally
had to get someone
to drive a few miles
in a crazy storm
to hit a power switch
somewhere in this closet
for our development tool.
So as we all worked from home,
we got the support we needed.
So this is how I know
that we weren't meant
to have an on-prem solution.
But there are some
other reasons, too.
We have-- before I jump into
some of the other reasons,
I guess our journey really
began with the same journey
that most of the folks that
have onboarded themselves
onto Google Cloud
have engaged with.
And it was really about, we knew
as a data analytics company,
we were going to have massive
amounts of scale coming in.
And how would we be able
to elastically scale?
We didn't have, at the
time, tens of millions
of dollars of funding to go
build a crazy data center
to handle that level of scale.
And at the end of
the day, how do we
get folks that are in
the financial services
industries, that are
massive retailers-- how
do we get them comfortable with
deploying onto our platform
when we talk about security
and privacy and GDPR
and really great challenges
that we face in technology?
How do we get them
comfortable with that?
And knowing that
Google literally
has laser beam-protected
floors-- like,
we don't have them
in our office.
I don't know if you
have them in yours.
But also even down
to custom-built,
embedded hardware to make sure
that the hardware hasn't been
tampered with, that
it's not been hacked,
et cetera, which if you've been
seeing the news, it happens.
And so how do we get
our enterprise customers
comfortable with that
level of security?
So that was kind of the
beginning of our journey.
And I'm excited to share a
little more today about where
we kind of fell into.
There's much more to cloud
than just, I would almost say,
these menial things
of hey, look.
We can have reduced costs.
We can scale quickly.
These are, maybe, table stakes.
But there are some
really cool things
that help us think different
about the challenges
that we face and that we solve
for our enterprise customers.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And just for the
audience, is anyone
familiar with seeing that closet
photo in your own offices?
I'm sure it's pretty common.
And we're also
familiar with that
need to scale very quickly
in a short amount of time.
Can you elaborate
more on this amount
of scale of traffic and data
that you've seen at Quantum?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah,
I'm super excited.
I love scale.
I'm passionate about taking
on large amounts of data.
And how do we ingest it and
actually get insights from it?
So a typical month
at Quantum, we
will take in over
600 million sessions.
So to put that in
perspective, it's
about 300 million
unique visitors.
And that's about one
ninth of the internet.
That's one ninth of the
folks that are online.
We also take 89
billion HTTPS requests.
And that's, to put in
perspective of scale,
about one fifth the
number of queries
that Google search
handles in a given month.
So-- massive amounts of scale.
We handle 1 and 1/2
petabytes of network traffic,
a half of a petabyte
of cloud storage,
and over 14 petabytes
of BigQuery analysis.
So this is just an
overwhelming amount of data.
It kind of feels like just
an onslaught of information.
And you know, what
was fun about cloud
is, how do we build an
infrastructure, do that?
We don't need to.
We can hit a couple buttons
in Google Console and scale.
And we have some incredible
retailers I mentioned earlier.
Imagine at Black Friday--
I know [INAUDIBLE]
yesterday was talking
about Kohl's and his
experience in cloud
and being able to
scale so quickly.
I mean, imagine a
day that you need
to handle three to five
times your normal workload,
and you just hit a switch.
It was pretty exciting on
how we can engage in cloud
and have so much success
with so much ease.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Yeah, and this can't
be an easy challenge.
How are you able to support
this amount of data traffic--
over a petabyte?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so it's--
they have this massive scale.
How many of you
have been involved
with big data projects?
And how many of you have had
incredible insights coming out
of those big data projects?
So for the viewer audience,
not that many, right?
Everyone kind of
put their hand down.
And so we collect
incredible amounts of data.
But no one cares about
what you collect.
I don't care about hoarding
information or hoarding things.
I care about, what insights
can I deliver from that data?
And so that's where that
massive scale analysis really
comes into play.
And so when we talk
about us as a company
and how to get great
insights from it,
I like to relate it
to flying an airline.
I know all of us-- and
many of us have flown here.
But many of us fly often.
And when I'm flying to Iceland
today, and I'll tell you,
I didn't buy the jet to
take that flight to Iceland.
I'm buying a seat, right?
And so with our
sporadic workload--
so we have folks coming into
our console and our platform
and trying to look at
insights and questions
they want to answer.
Are they doing well?
Is their hybrid cloud
performing well?
Is their on-prem and
their cloud solutions
performing the same or
even better in cloud?
They have questions they want
to answer, but it's sporadic.
It's not constantly in our
platform asking questions.
So it's sporadic.
It's very similar to, I need
to take a flight somewhere.
I need a very small
amount of compute power--
or, a large amount
of compute power
for a small amount of time.
I don't need to take--
I don't need to buy the jet.
I want a seat on the airline.
So we had that same
challenge with our workload.
And what's really exciting is
how the cloud can empower this.
And we realized quickly that
our success was really about,
how do we ingest
this data and find
novel ways to present insights
from that large amount of data
set?
And that was what was
going to differentiate us.
It wasn't about
how we collected.
It wasn't about how it
looked in our console.
It was, what insights can we
deliver for our customers?
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Yeah, and this data scale
is handled by BigQuery,
as you mentioned.
And a lot of our
customers at Google Cloud
are doing very innovative things
with BigQuery at the moment.
But as many people know, it's
not the only data science
platform.
You know, there
are other vendors
that offer other solutions.
You mentioned a really funny
story about your son earlier.
Do you mind telling the
audience about that story?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so I was
writing an article for Forbes
about our experience in
cloud and different takeaways
that we've had at massive scale.
And I was writing about
BigQuery and about how
it's been transformational
for our business, how we've
been empowering our customers
to have new insights that they'd
never even knew
that they could ask,
some automation
about the processes
that they discover
where frustration
is happening online.
And it's hilarious because
my 9-year-old son--
his name is Cody--
he seriously says to me,
"But Dad, can't Amazon
and Microsoft do this, too?"
And I was kind of,
like, blown away
by he knew the names of
the other two large cloud
providers.
And you know, it's funny
that you ask this, Cody--
absolutely.
Like, I really believe that
Amazon and Azure-- right,
the AWS and Azure-- can deliver
on massive-scale compute
and massive-scale data analysis.
But the challenge that we have
is our workload is sporadic.
And I don't want
to spin up, let's
say, 50,000 CPUs to
do an analysis that
might take a minute
or two to spin up,
run my query for five
seconds, and shut it all down.
It's just not
financially feasible.
And so, I think one of the
really unique differentiations
of Google Cloud has been this
fractional lease of analysis,
of big compute, to chug away
at massive scale of data.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit about some
of the other things
that we believe
that massive compute
brings to the table
when it comes to thinking
different about data analysis.
But for us-- and what
I told my son was--
absolutely.
But fractional leasing
has been a differentiator.
And I think if you have
either used BigQuery,
or if you know folks that are,
they'll talk to you about that.
That same fractional
lease, that massive amount
of query capabilities
for a small period time,
is really one of the unique
features of BigQuery.
STEPHANIE WONG: And the
title of this session
is Apple's 1997 Promise
to Think Different.
Can you talk more about
what you mean by that?
How are you thinking different
with your teams right now?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so this
is one of the best marketing
campaigns of all time.
And you know, I know from
looking at the audience
that there's some of us
that probably remember
this campaign very well.
And it was talking about
Apple's engineering fortitude,
and likening it to geniuses
that were brave enough
to take on the
world and change it.
It may be crazy enough--
I think the words
were crazy enough
to try to change the world.
And then they actually
accomplished it.
But it wasn't about
buying an Apple computer,
and all of a sudden,
you thought different.
It was simply, like, we think
different like these geniuses.
What I thought was amazing--
and where I came up with this
concept was--
when we engaged with BigQuery,
we basically took our handcuffs
off, these handcuffs that
we had no idea existed,
in terms of massive-scale
query analysis.
We can start asking
questions that we never
thought about asking because
now, we didn't have any rails.
We didn't have indexes.
We didn't have certain types
of queries that we could run.
We could run a question
across a day, a month, a year,
and start getting insights that
we never really knew about.
So my belief is that we are now
able to think different about,
how do we solve business
problems for our customers,
for our enterprises, in ways
that we never really explored?
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
I think you also talked about
machine intelligence a bit too,
right?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so one of
the things that we discovered--
and we're a startup.
We went from just a few
years ago from two people
to there are 80-plus today.
As that journey
happens, you start
to learn-- for me-- a little
bit about that selling process.
And we used to talk.
And I think it's kind of funny,
because Apple never really
talked about the
performance of the CPUs
and all the metrics
of memory, stuff that
techies, that we think
about, and we think
about we should share this.
What I learned
was, no one really
wants this concept about
machine intelligence.
We can talk about
AI, machine learning.
No one really cares about that.
They just want intelligence.
They just want answers
to their challenges
and their business needs.
And so that was a journey
that we went on and started
figuring out that we can
help customers automate some
of those human processes, some
of the things that they do
and they spend hours or days.
We can take
massive-scale compute
and solve them,
perhaps, in seconds.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
and machine intelligence
here, how--
can you talk about
some of the examples
that you've gone
through at your company?
How are you able to implement
this type of practice
and thinking?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, so
we've been able to take--
some of the things that we've
really solved for our customers
have been, when
I go to a website
and I'm having a bad experience,
how do I know about it?
I don't fill out surveys.
I don't call the company
and tell them, hey,
your website's broken.
I just leave.
So how do we figure out people
are having a bad experience?
And it turns out we can
look at the behavior.
They're clicking reload.
They're hitting the
back and forward button.
They're rage clicking
the that book a flight
or transact button.
And we can look at
those behaviors,
and with BigQuery, we
can start aggregating
around those behaviors
and discover these lead
to under-conversion.
And so we've automated
that process of discovery
and build that sort of human
discovery, human analysis
into our product.
So it's been really
transformational
for our enterprise
customers because they
don't have to spend days
wondering is this actually
impacting my business?
They can know about
it in seconds.
Another fantastic
one was the ability
to understand when did a problem
actually start occurring?
And for our
enterprise customers,
they had no way to
know when the bug was
introduced into their system.
They would spend
days looking at logs
and looking at release notes
and trying to figure it out.
What we're able to do is
spin up tens of thousands
of CPUs in Cloud Functions
and Google Compute
to analyze when did
this start happening
by replaying every session
that visited the website.
When did the indicator of
the issue start occurring?
So with massive-scale
compute, we
started solving problems that
our enterprise customers had
never even broached
because they just
didn't have 50,000,
100,000 CPUs lying around
in the data center.
So it's really been
amazing how cloud
has enabled us to
think different
about some of the challenges
that these enterprises
were facing.
And I think another one that's
been really a hot topic for us
in our space has been, how do we
take the high standard of care
with our customer data?
And a lot of it was left
to human configuration.
We know where sensitive
information was.
We know where there's
PCI information, or PII,
and either encrypt or mask it.
The problem with
that is it always
left it up to human error.
And how often was someone
looking at this type
of data and discovery?
And that discovery would happen.
We needed to automate that.
So we're now engaging with
Google's Sensitive Data API
and rolling this out, hopefully,
in the next short time
period, about instead of
waiting for humans to discover
that there's misconfiguration,
can't we just
have the computer
tell us that here's
an opportunity to improve the
data that we're collecting?
So that's just really great
ways and exciting ways
that we can engage
in machine learning,
massive-scale compute,
massive-scale query analysis
to automate some
of the functions
that we had to do as humans
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, and I
think a lot of our audience
probably wants to
know how they can
implement these practices
into their own organizations
as well?
Can you talk about some
exemplary use cases for them
to do this?
MARIO CIABARRA: Yeah, I think
there's not a prescriptive way
that you can take this
and bring it home to all
of your own organizations.
You have to take a look at, what
are some of the human processes
that we can automate?
And as you engage in cloud
scale and think about
compute in different
ways, I do believe
it will help you
think differently
about some of the
massive problems
that you engage in at your
enterprises and startups alike.
And so, here's my
thought process.
It's a very simple process.
And it just
literally the process
that we took to
discover, hey, how can we
automate some of these processes
with massive-scale compute?
And it's really
about, where are there
tasks that we face that
consume a lot of time?
How can we translate that
into a set of queries?
How can we take a look at
this massive-scale data
and understand, here's how
we automate that process.
Identifying key insights--
what will make people
engage in these results?
Like for us, it
was about revenue.
If we can talk about, if you do
this, you'll make $17 million,
that's when people started
saying, OK, these are insights
that I want to listen to.
Versus hey, here's
some graphs and charts.
Thank you for the
anecdotal evidence.
I'm going to go on about my
priorities in my daily job.
So when we can connect
that with revenue,
that's where,
really, people start
to engage in those results.
And then just engaging
across teams--
so we learned a little bit
about cross-team, and maybe
the intersection
of domains, where
we believe that this is where
creativity is really born.
And so we can get product
teams and engineering
and DevOps and business
teams and executive teams all
aligned on where the biggest
impacts are for their business.
We can start to make a--
what we believe, to say the
words-- digital transformation.
Those words mean a little bit
different for each company,
but a digital transformation
on having everyone
aligned on where are my biggest
successes for my organization,
and how do we get everyone
to take action as opposed
to, maybe, confirmation
bias, or everyone
having their own agendas?
So that's been pretty exciting.
So following that
recipe to success,
we've had about three
or four iterations
on how do we think
different about our data.
And I think it's something that
the audience could take away.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you.
Yeah, thank you so
much for sharing
some of those wins that you've
gotten with Google Cloud,
and kind of enabling
our audience
to be able to achieve their
own digital transformation.
MARIO CIABARRA: Awesome.
Well Stephanie, it was
a pleasure being here.
And I thank you
all for attending.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right,
thank you, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]